i think you'll get a kick out of this uh
maria bartiromo on fox news and fox
business has become one of the most
weaponized brown nosers for everything
trump and everything andy biden she used
to be a pretty serious financial
journalist when i was growing up and
started following the stock market she
was reporting from the floor of the new
york stock exchange and doing really
good interviews of fortune 500 ceos and
she has become nothing but a trump brown
noser and a right-wing extremist at
least as far as her on on screen
presentation
and she was interviewing house minority
leader kevin mccarthy
no moderate centrist by any stretch of
the imagination i mean mccarthy is a
right wing loon
and she brings up impeaching biden like
oh would you definitely impeach biden if
you take control of the house
and mccarthy doesn't go for it
as much as mccarthy would love to
impeach biden if he thought he could get
away with it and if he thought that it
would be good politically
even mccarthy seems to be playing a
little bit of a whoa whoa whoa let's
slow down for a second here maria this
is fascinating to see let's take a look
i spoke with one of your colleagues
on friday on fox business greg murphy
and he told me that all of the things
that he is seeing from president biden
uh are impeachable
but the congress is worried about it
what what
what things are those i mean this is
just out of this world nuttery teaching
him because they're not so confident
about his number two here's greg murphy
i want to get your reaction to this
watch
by the way
imagine thinking hey you know what we
could impeach and remove biden but then
kamala becomes the president and that's
not good so we're not going to imp what
what are you talking about
i think there's going to be plenty of
foot there's plenty if you look at
afghanistan you look at the border
crisis you look at so many of these
different things the sad thing is maria
look at who's number two
look at who's number two i think number
two and think about that
impeach biden for getting out of
afghanistan
which trump was scheduled to do if he
had won and remained president why why
would you impeach him impeach biden
because of the situation at the border
which is essentially unchanged from when
trump was president what are these
people talking about and the viewers
don't know they just have no idea
they're like oh yeah yeah it sounds
right two is worse than number one so
this is the predict predicament that
we're in but these offenses that this
president has done against the heart and
soul of this country against law and
order i think stands our grounds for
impeachable offenses
congressman what about that will you
move to impeach president biden
look one thing we learned that the
democrats did is they they used
impeachment for political reason we
believe in the rule of law we're not
going to pick and choose just because
somebody has power we're going to uphold
the law at any time if someone breaks
the law and the ramification comes
impeachment we would move towards that
but we're not going to use it for
political purposes our focus is going to
be securing our border making us energy
independent
bringing these prices down making our
schools safe in our streets again and
holding this administration accountable
and we will take the facts to wherever
the facts go because america has been
through too much anyway so i don't
believe a word he's saying and what i
mean by that is
mccarthy would be right there impeaching
biden for sure if he thought it would
help him politically but right now he
knows it's too crazy crazy for the
minority leader of the house to just
come out and say our plan is to impeach
joe biden now as a counterpoint marjorie
taylor greene
is saying that and the things she's
saying are way crazier than the things
even maria bartoromo is saying as crazy
as impeaching biden for getting out of
afghanistan would be
listen to what marjorie taylor green has
planned if republicans take control of
the house
congressional record that we can now
expose on that laptop
here's what we do after that right
we need to impeach kamala harris
[Applause]
why can't they get kamala harris's name
correct
at this point
at in all on all honesty
do you think they're doing it on purpose
that they it's a subtle dig
i mean you know like for example you
know i say tulsi gabbard and i admit
it's a completely juvenile dig i think
she's a completely unserious person and
the idea that i can't even be bothered
to to learn her name i find it funny uh
when it comes to kamala do you think
they're doing it on purpose do you think
they genuinely can't learn kamala
harris's name like what do you what do
you think is behind it
because you can't encourage and promote
raise money for criminal rioters and
expect to serve the interest of the
people the great people in the united
states that is that is a conflict of
interest
she is not kidding
there is a group within the republican
party
and it may be the mainstream of the
republican party it remains to be seen
in the sense of
we'll see who gets behind it if and when
they take control of the house there is
a group that is determined to impeach
joe biden how do we know well some of
them have already written up articles of
impeachment they don't go anywhere
because republicans don't control the
house but lauren beaubert
has written up articles of impeachment
marjorie taylor green has for now people
like kevin mccarthy are just holding
short they're saying wow
we'll impeach if that's what should
happen but he's not committing to an
impeachment
um
they're going to do it
and this is yet another reason why if
republicans do take control of the house
or imagine if they take control of both
the house and senate in november
it is going to be
obstruction city biden will get nothing
else done and
there may be an impeachment trial
to serve as a distraction during the
second two years the the the third and
fourth years the second half
of joe biden's first term as president
uh they're going to do it when they're
they're telling us they're going to do
it and i believe that they're going to
do it and it's going to be a nightmare